sie waren Direktor von SAP Pariser sie
wissen wie dieses Atomkraftwerk
funktioniert wie können wir uns die
Situation im Moment vorstellen
ist
die Situation verschlechtert sich mit
jeder Woche der Anwesenheit der Besatzer
auf dem Gelände
sie beschädigten unter anderem das
Verwaltungsgebäude das Schulungszentrum
und sogar das Reaktorgebäude von Block 1
Transformer außerdem beschädigten sie
den Transformator den Haupttransformator
und den Block 6 des Kernkraftwerks
[Musik]
sie funktionierten es in ihre
Militärbasis um und Sie haben
tatsächlich alle Gebäude besetzt die
stark geschützt sind und für die
Notfallmaßnahmen benötigt werden wenn im
Kernkraftwerk etwas passiert
das Krisenzentrum das aus Zentrum für
Ingenieure und so weiter
all diese Strukturen sind jetzt unter
Besatzung
die Soldaten nutzen sie als Schlafplatz
zum Essen für alles was sie wollen
[Musik]
und sie haben eine Menge Ausrüstung
mitgebracht militärische Ausrüstung wie
Militärlastwagen
und sie haben es einfach in der
Turbinenhalle von Block Nummer 1 und
Block Nummer 2 gelagert
und das bedeutet dass sie dort eine sehr
große Brandgefahr schaffen wenn es zu
einem Brand kommt gibt es keine
Möglichkeit das Feuer zu bekämpfen weil
der Zugang durch die Fahrzeuge blockiert
wird die in den turbinenhallen stehen
[Musik]
niemand weiß was sich in diesen
Lastwagen befindet
sich um explosive Materialien und auch
um waffenhandeln die detonieren und dann
Sprengungen verursachen können
was denn noch das Personal der Anlage
kann sich nur eingeschränkt auf dem
Gelände der Anlage bewegen da das
gesamte Gelände durch die Besatzer
vermiet ist
schon zu Hause
telefonind by the Perry mit
sie sind im Moment wahrscheinlich einer
der meist beschäftigten Menschen wenn
wir die Situation im Lande mit all den
Problemen sehen die sie mit ihren
Kernkraftwerken haben stations
[Musik]
wissen Sie es ist eine sehr schwierige
Situation im Land mit der
Stromversorgung durch all diese Schäden
bei der Energieinfrastruktur bei der
verteilungsinfrastruktur den
Umspannwerken und den Leitungen durch
die unsere Kraftwerke an das Netz
angeschlossen werden
zum Moment
alle sechs Blöcke des Kernkraftwerk
saporicia befinden sich momentan im
abschaltmodus und in der Kaltabschaltung
und das ist sehr schlecht für das System
und auch für das Kraftwerk selbst denn
der Winter kommt als Winter kamen so
Temperatur
sinkt könnte das eine Katastrophe werden
denn das Kernkraftwerk ist die einzige
Energieversorgung für die Region in der
es sich befindet
für den Betrieb von Sicherheitssystemen
und wichtige Geräte wie Inc Ausrüstung
das ist Ausrüstung die für die Kontrolle
der Kühlung der Reaktoren erforderlich
ist
wir brauchen dort Wärme wir sind
glücklich wenn wir bald mindestens eine
Einheit dort in Betrieb nehmen um Dampf
aus der Reaktoranlage zu bekommen
und so die Bedingungen schaffen die für
den normalen Betrieb auch im
kaltstart-modus aller Reaktoren
erforderlich sind
normal Paris
[Musik]
stehen sie in ständigem Kontakt mit dem
Personal dass die Anlage betreibt
yes Nord
ja aber nicht mit dem gesamten Personal
sondern mit der Betriebsleitung
Kontakt mit ihnen und haben jeden Morgen
Besprechungen mit ihnen und sie
berichten uns über die Situation
was haben sie Ihnen heute berichtet
die Mitarbeiter stehen unter starkem
Druck der Russen
in Moskau die Russen haben in Moskau
eine Scheinfirma gegründet und einen
russischen Direktor für das Kraftwerk
ernannt
im Moment versuchen Sie das Personal zu
drängen Arbeitsverträge mit Russland zu
unterzeichnen Sie versuchen von ihnen
die Unterschrift unter einen Vertrag zu
bekommen der bedeutet dass sie von der
ukrainischen at Energiebehörde
innergroatom zur russischen Rosatom
versetzt werden
[Musik]
all diese Aktionen sind illegal sie
verstoßen gegen das ukrainische Gesetz
aber das Personal hat die Wahl entweder
diesen Vertrag zu unterschreiben oder
geschlagen oder gefoltert zu werden
wir hatten viele Fälle in denen die
Russen das Personal gefangen genommen
haben eine Person wurde getötet und eine
andere wurde angeschossen und verwundet
[Musik]
und
etwa 100 Menschen wissen wir dass sie
von ihnen gefangen genommen wurden von
einigen wissen wir nicht was mit ihnen
passiert ist
[Musik]
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
sind die Leute die jetzt in der Anlage
selbst arbeiten in einer Art Geiselhaft
sie können nicht weg
ja
im Moment ist es ihnen verboten das
Gebiet zu verlassen
und so haben wir die Arbeitsplätze hier
in Kiew zur Verfügung gestellt andere
Einrichtungen wie andere Kernkraftwerke
wir haben vier Kernkraftwerke und drei
davon sind auf Ukrainisch kontrolliertem
Gebiet
so haben wir den Mitarbeitern die
versucht haben die russische Besatzung
zu verlassen vorgeschlagen in unseren
anderen Einrichtungen in der Ukraine zu
arbeiten
[Musik]
aber im Moment halten sie alle Leute ab
das Gebiet zu verlassen
sie sitzen also dort wie Geiseln und sie
drängen sie dazu diese Verträge zu
unterschreiben
soweit ich das verstehe ist der
menschliche Faktor sehr wichtig wenn man
einen Kernkraftwerk betreibt wenn das
Personal unter einem solchen Druck steht
welches risikobirkt das
ist
personality normalerweise sollte ein
Mitarbeiter über nukleare Sicherheit
nachdenken das ist seine Pflicht aber
jetzt sitzt er da drinnen und wird
abgelenkt von der Besetzung von all
diesen Waffen die auf ihn gerichtet sind
und dann denkt ihr darüber nach was mit
seiner Familie los ist oder mit seinen
Eltern
[Musik]
Problemen
die Russen zum Beispiel pro ukrainische
Inhalte in seinem Telefon finden wird er
einfach festgenommen gefoltert und
geschlagen
[Musik]
in
sometimes 3 manchmal lassen sie diese
Leute einfach zwei Wochen nach der
Gefangennahme wieder frei und sie kommen
in einem völlig anderen geistigen
Zustand heraus nachdem sie gefoltert
wurden sie sind nicht einmal in der Lage
zu erzählen was mit ihnen passiert ist
aber die Russen brauchen das ukrainische
Personal um die Anlage zu betreiben sie
können es nicht austauschen ich kann mir
vorstellen dass das sehr mutige Leute
sind
sehr mutig sie haben den Generaldirektor
des Werks Herrn muraschov gef angenommen
und ihn etwa vier Tage lang festgehalten
und murrachov wurde auf ukrainisches
Gebiet entlassen
[Musik]
sie den Personalleiter den
stellvertretenden Leiter des Werks und
eine weitere Person gefangen genommen
Personal of the plant sie haben also
einfach die Verantwortlichen abgesetzt
und jetzt jemanden eingesetzt der nicht
so stark und nicht so mutig ist um ihnen
Widerstand zu leisten
können
einfach sagen okay jeder macht was wir
wollen unterschreibt den Vertrag und
jetzt ist es ein russisches Werk
ist ein gefälschtes Referendum
kann diese Anlage den einfach so an das
russische Energiesystem angeschlossen
werden was ist das Ziel dieser Besatzung
du kannst tun was immer Du willst wenn
du Zeit und Geld hast
theoretisch geht das praktisch gesehen
kann man es nicht weil die Anlage aus
sechs Einheiten besteht das ist massiv
[Musik]
das größte Kernkraftwerk in Europa und
es erfordert spezielle Leitungen und
eine besondere Infrastruktur nur um
diese Energie ins Netz zu leiten
im Moment sind die meisten Leitungen die
den Strom außer poricia mit dem
ukrainischen System verbinden beschädigt
dennoch gab es von Anfang an nicht genug
Leitungen um zum Beispiel die Krim
wieder anzuschließen und im Moment sind
alle diese Leitungen beschädigt es gibt
also keine physische Möglichkeit
saporiscia vom ukrainischen System zu
trennen und an die Krim anzuschließen
international
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde Raphael grossi
appelliert an die Russen diese Situation
zu beenden er sagte dass diese Situation
sehr gefährlich sei er wiederholte das
mehrmals gibt es momentan irgendeine
Möglichkeit der Verhandlung
soweit ich weiß versucht herauszi sein
Bestes um Verhandlungen zu führen und
eine Sicherheitszone um das Kraftwerk
einzurichten
unserem ukrainischen Verständnis sollten
diese Zonen die Besetzung des Kraftwerks
einschließen
es sollten sich also keine Militärs
innerhalb des Kraftwerks befinden
und das ist was wir voll und ganz
unterstützen
ich kann nur sagen dass dies momentan
das gefährlichste Atomkraftwerk der Welt
ist weil die Russen dort sind
haben sie wirklich Angst vor einem
Atomunfall
sagen aber ein strahlenunfall liegt sehr
nahe und wir waren schon drei Mal in
unmittelbarer Nähe zu diesem
strahlenunfall
[Musik]
weil das Kraftwerk stark von der
Stromversorgung abhängig ist
wenn die interne Stromversorgung gerade
nicht funktioniert weil alle Blöcke im
abkühlungsmodus sind dann braucht man
eine externe Stromversorgung um die
Pumpen zu versorgen die zur Kühlung der
Reaktoren eingesetzt werden
und sechs Becken mit abgebrannten
Brennelementen wir brauchen konstante
Kühlung für diese Reaktoren und für
diesen abgebrannten Brennstoff auch wenn
der Reaktor nicht mehr funktioniert hat
er immer noch Wärme produziert konstante
Wärme die eine Restwärme aus der
vorherigen Reaktion ist und man sollte
sie ständig kühlen
kostenlos
und danach verteilen sich die
Brennelemente im oder gehen als
gasförmige Produkte in die Luft und die
Umwelt
products und dann haben wir einen
gefährlichen strahlenunfall
[Musik]
dran denn sie haben alle Leitungen
beschädigt die das Atomkraftwerk mit der
externen Stromversorgung verbinden
wir hatten drei Fälle in denen wir das
Kraftwerk auf Dieselgeneratoren
umgestellt haben
die Dieselgeneratoren laufen automatisch
an und versorgen die Pumpen mit Strom
wenn wir diese Situation mit dem Unfall
in Fukushima vergleichen dann ist das
die erste Stufe dass die Stromversorgung
ausfällt das ist was auch in Fukushima
passiert ist
beziehungsweise SWAT Treffen
nach dem Tsunami dadurch wurde die
externe Stromversorgung beschädigt
und jetzt hier in saporicia ist wegen
der russischen Besatzung die externe
Stromversorgung genauso beschädigt
in Fukushima war es der Tsunami der
durch das Erdbeben ausgelöst wurde aber
erst 30 Minuten später die Anlage
erreichte und alle Dieselgeneratoren zum
Stillstand brachte so dass es keine
Stromversorgung für die Kühlpumpen gab
die Kernschmelze begann innerhalb von
drei Stunden und die Radioaktivität die
in Fukushima freigesetzt wurde
[Musik]
ich will los wenn wir die
Dieselgeneratoren in saporicia in dieser
Situation verlieren
haben wir das gleiche Szenario so Ende
waren bereits drei Mal in diesem Modus
in dem wir uns nur auf die
Zuverlässigkeit des diesel-generators
und den Dieselkraftstoff verlassen und
der reicht für zehn Tage
zur Zeit noch zehn Tage
zehn Tage weil wir Nachschub besorgt
haben und drei Tage lang an den
Generatoren gearbeitet haben und jetzt
gerade den Treibstoff nachfüllen
können Sie nachts noch schlafen
ja natürlich du musst schlafen um mit
der Situation fertig zu werden
bereitet sich die Ukraine bereits auf
dieses Szenario eines nuklearen Unfalls
vor
eigentlich
nicht vorbereiten natürlich haben wir
einige Übungen gemacht einige Schulungen
für das gesamte Personal
natürlich haben wir einige
organisatorische Maßnahmen getroffen
einige logistische Maßnahmen für die
Evakuierung des Personals Engineering
ist dass die Russen das größte
Kernkraftwerk Europas besetzt haben und
in eine Militärbasis umfunktioniert
haben
[Musik]
man muss sie nur von dort entfernen und
alles wird ruhig und reibungslos
funktionieren wie zuvor und das ist es
worauf wir uns konzentrieren müssen
wir diskutieren gerade die Frage ob
Russland taktische Atomwaffen in der
Ukraine einsetzen könnte aber diese
Situation hier scheint viel gefährlicher
und viel wahrscheinlicher oder es macht
modernes and much my likel
hängt davon ab wie stark und welche
Menge Brennstoff beschädigt wird
es ist eine Menge Kernmaterial in der
Anlage
wenn wir also nur über ein Brennelement
sprechen werden die Auswirkungen auf die
Umwelt mehr oder weniger gering sein
[Musik]
wenn es sich um den gesamten Reaktorkern
handelt wird es sich um einen Unfall
größeren Ausmaßes Handeln
alles vom kleinen bis zu einem großen
Unfall liegt im Bereich der russischen
Möglichkeiten
[Musik]
wie stark wäre ein Land wie Deutschland
im schlimmsten Fall davon betroffen
auch hier kommt es darauf an worüber wir
sprechen
es sind sechs Reaktoren voll mit
nuklearen Material
und dann ist da noch die Anlage die
ebenfalls eine kerntechnische Anlage ist
nämlich ein Trockenlager für abgebrannte
Brennelemente
das ist Trockenlager befindet sich unter
freiem Himmel auf dem Gelände des
Kraftwerks
handelt sich um 174 Betonbehälter mit
jeweils 24 Brennelementen
mit abgebrannten Brennelementen würde zu
einer strahlungsgefährdung und zu einer
Verteilung dieser nuklearen Materialien
führen
wie groß die Katastrophe sein wird hängt
von der Höhe des Schadens ab
wenn es nur ein Brennelement betrifft
wird dies nur ein kleiner Schaden sein
wenn es das volle Nuklearmaterial ist
wird es zu einer Katastrophe kommen wie
es sie bisher noch nicht gegeben hat
stehen sie in Kontakt mit Herrn grossi
ich stehe in Kontakt mit ihm und während
der Entlassung von Herrn murrachov dem
Generaldirektor von saporicia hat uns
Herr grossy sehr geholfen ich war also
ständig in Kontakt mit ihm und habe auch
Informationen erhalten und ihm
Informationen darüber geschickt was vor
sich geht
in Ordnung
haben sie Hoffnung dass es Herr grossi
bis zu einer Einigung schafft
sie oder vielleicht die Vereinten
Nationen vielleicht die peacekeepers
oder wer auch immer
aber es ist die einzige vernünftige
Lösung für dieses Problem und sie sollte
erreicht werden
und sie wird am Ende auch erreicht
werden da bin ich mir sicher das hoffe
ich nicht nur ich bin mir sicher aber
was bis dahin passiert zwischen heute
und der endgültigen Lösung bis wir die
volle über das saporissia Atomkraftwerk
haben das weiß niemandă
[Musik]